THG TO
UP.VEA SIG
PRESIDENT Y
GOVERNMENTTHCOULD ANE WHO WHEN
INVESTIGATED FORT,ELDS POWER ASF
THOUGH HE IS
ACUN
UNLED E,
OUACY IS IN GRAVNGER- F HE CANE
DEPARTMENT WILL TRY TON
PRESIDENT RELATED TO THESEMER
BUT MET GARLAND IS A FRIEND
AND ERNT O.
HE'S A
HE'SER SD HE WOULD GO TO THE TO
IFT'E EVIDENCEPOS INDICATIONCER
ANOFCE JOHEA
NOT STOPNG WITH THE FOOT
SOLDIERS.
IT'S GOING TO BE GENERALS.
ANTHE BIGGEST GENERAL OF ALLOURL
I DO THINK TS ILL
BE INDICTED. U
AL OF TATES E
FORMERRESIDENT OF TH
, THOU
BE
E THE MAINDLES
-NG AN
INDICTMENT OF DONALD TRUMPYOU B?
>> WITH THE POSSIBILITY OF A
O WRONG.Y, SOMEONE BASICALLYBELM
HAVING AN INDINTCOG A FORMER WOF
CI
BUCTIND ERLE
TIBE WEIGHINLE
EA
IT'S WORSE TO SAE PRES
OF TATES CAN HOLD ON
TO TAKES
IN